everyone in town knows the tortilla
bakery and everyone in yodeler a Mexican
town near the Pacific Coast also knows
the owner ni de Lozano supplies the
staple food for IO close people it's a
busy place but all is not well at the
bakery an Ida has to run it alone with
her workers half a year ago her husband
was abducted right out of the shop hello
methanol she says they took two months
to call and demand a ransom I wanted
proof that my husband was still alive
they wanted half a million pesos or
thirty thousand euros but first I at
least have to speak to him otherwise how
can I be sure
crime is flourishing in Mexico not least
in rural areas criminal gangs do not
hesitate a kidnap extort or kill people
they abducted an ideas husband in front
of dozens of witnesses your people on
the buffer she says they went with him
across the market square even though
many people were there I saw them myself
they walked right past me I thought they
were bodyguards and they went into the
town hall my husband was supposed to
become mayor soon outside of town five
corpses were found an Ida's husband was
not among them still she's drawn to the
place where the killer's left the bodies
behind and she's not alone many other
families have suffered similar fates
armed men accompanied the group it's
safer that way they're the I outland
militia they not the police were the
ones who found the bodies as commando
room wild or amisha tells us I am in
mother lastima book he says I'm sick of
having to keep digging up bodies often
of my friends we have police and
authorities that earn money and enjoy
privileges but they don't protect us
from the killers so we decided to defend
ourselves and we set up a vigilante
militia el pueblo cual vamos la policía
comunitaria these militias or policia co
meritorious are springing up all across
Mexico it's because the police can't
come to grips with the country's crime
problem the militias appeal for
volunteers and many thousands have
responded these people know all too well
help dangerous the gangs are so they
prefer to remain anonymous like Raimundo
Nava most of them here are farmers who
until recently paid the gangs protection
money out of fear for their lives
whoever refuses to pay risks being
killed Raimundo Nava works in an
agricultural cooperative but only
part-time because he's also a militia
member he tells us that last night they
broke in again and made off with 30
sacks of hibiscus flowers and cash yeah
no la one thing yay I can't take it
anymore he says we suffer so much from
this constant peril I'm not talking
about one or two incidents here crimes
are committed every day it's a business
it's like an industry and who knows
where it will all lead to conserve it
donde como
after work the farmers turn into a small
army they trade in their tools for
rifles and shotguns Cutler is under arms
the militia a thousand men strong and
they say that since they took over from
the police there's been no sign of the
criminals they show their presence by
patrolling through town and try to
collect information about crimes from
the other locals raymundo the farmer is
now a commander
the market traders are just as terrified
of the gang says the farmers are the
militia tries to help but not everyone
trusts them some don't like the idea of
vigilantism others object to having even
more Mexicans carrying guns and fighting
violence with violence suddenly no one
here knows of thing about any gangs a
woman at the market complains to
commandant in Nava she says militiamen
detained her husband because he
allegedly didn't pay his debts and
imprisoned him without evidence she says
not that evening of course there are
objections Raimundo tells us but the
real problem is that the police won't go
after the criminals we do but as a
militia we have to depend on our
neighbors okay trail Manos otro Omo Omo
defenses people say I utla has quietened
down since the vigilantes started
patrolling many support them the
criminals most of whom have ties to the
country's powerful drug cartels then
move on to places where they don't face
any militias where the police are there
only opponents we hear the police are
actually on the take that they collect
bribes and ignore the crimes the sad
fact is that Mexico's justice system
souls only two percent of the country's
violent crimes three days after we leave
these pictures were broadcast on Mexican
TV they show Raimundo Nava and hundreds
of other militiamen arresting 12 police
officers and their former chief who had
allegedly worked together with criminals
it's another new high point in a war in
which it's every man for himself
Mexico's government gives the militias
of free reign and even special rights to
possess firearms and detain suspects
politicians are so afraid of the crime
syndicates that none are willing to
speak to us then finally one city
councilman tries to explain anonymously
lyric video he says politicians at the
federal level the Senators and
Representatives all know very well
what's going on here but for them the
problems are very complex the problems
are too big and there aren't enough
opportunities there aren't enough people
there's no intelligence on the gangs
either we have some possibilities but
they're not enough Posadas parasail
awards eat elegans yeah I muchas pero
noise who visited oriya the great beauty
of this country stands in almost
perverse contrast to the crimes
committed here and to the fear that
people harbor mexico has more than half
a million police officers but the
vigilante leaders say they've achieved
more with just a few thousand members
but even they can't permanently rollback
organized crime they can't protect all
of Mexico's 115 million people when we
enter this restaurant we wonder why it
and many others are totally deserted at
lunchtime the owner tells us her story
much is afraid of being recognized
difficile de creer que it's hard to
believe she says but the gangs have the
entire town in their grip and my guests
don't come here anymore out of fear
until now I've been lucky but I know
that sometime they'll show up and demand
protection money if I want to stay in
business she refers to a friend of hers
an architect he was building a housing
complex when the president of the town
administration asked him to contact
certain people these people asked for
ten percent of the revenue so that
construction could continue securely as
if by coincidence ten percent was also
the level of his own profit he has small
children and says he doesn't know what
to do next I keep focus edathala team
Aldrin there's not much left to do he
says and we'd be finished soon if I pay
I'd have secure work but I don't think
it's acceptable we cannot do that
because in the end we'd only be there
silent accomplices and that keep doing
with us whatever they want yes I think
that it looks at it big I like a man but
these self defense initiatives have two
sides last month at vigilante roadblocks
like these two cars with tourists were
shot at because they didn't stop driving
through the country we had to stop at
dozens of such barriers many of the
farmers defending their villages conceal
their faces for fear of the killer gangs
they feel they're doing the right thing
because the state is failing to protect
them it's almost going to occur it was
drunk we are simple people he says who
just want peace in our villages and
homes and we no longer going to allow
certain people to show up here and
disturb that piece demand protection
money and treat us like slaves
unsupported ezell's give you an element
she says the police come here take
people out of our midst and abuse them
we don't dare go to the authorities
anymore because you can't be sure that
afterwards it won't be your turn
once they know who you are they just
wait until they catch you alone this
woman says we made a decision to protect
ourselves even if it costs us our lives
we decided for the sake of our families
what's the farm merely the murderers
gangs are destroying the fabric of a
whole country Mexico's victims are the
witnesses to a creeping process of
failing statehood ni de lausanne didn't
always sit together with her neighbors
so often today she says they all share
the same memories traumas and hopes all
those at this table have lost partners
sons or daughters like nati Castro's
fifteen-year-old daughter Maria who one
day didn't come home from school it'll
know if it'll kill but them not he says
it's totally devastating because you
never find out what they've done to our
loved ones whether they're still alive
or dead these people have no idea what
they do to families they destroy the
entire family the peace and calm we once
knew will never get it back Phineas
Thunder biome devaglia is wherever you
go in Mexico it's always the same the
only differences are the names of the
gangs of kidnappers all over the country
are modeled DNA mexico secuestrado
nosotros tenemos we thirst for justice
we hunger for what's right but in this
country waiting for the government to
deliver isn't going to help us perhaps
the militias would have protected their
families perhaps but by encouraging
vigilante militias the Mexican state is
looking increasingly powerless
you